all right welcome back to the program we
sadly and tragically had a
guest no call no show on us last minute
but it's a great opportunity since we
missed live calls last week because of
the election and the craziness
to hear from a few folks through the
discord at davidpakman.com
discord let's uh first go
to laura from richmond laura from
richmond
you were on uh what's on your mind today
laura
hey there can oh boy hold on one second
laura we have uh
we don't have things properly uh cued in
i can hear you but just bear with me
just just one moment and we're gonna be
your your audio is coming out of a very
very strange place
and we need it coming out of a normal
place okay laura you are i can now hear
you in the right spot
awesome uh well today's my birthday
happy birthday
thank you um i just wanted to say that
um
i watched your live stream of the vice
presidential
debate and also um
kamala and biden's acceptance speeches
and it was it was a great experience
thank you thank you for doing that for
us thank you for watching it
um so my question today
revolves around the 25th amendment right
i haven't really heard a lot about that
lately but it seems like
the more trump seems to be getting
unhinged yeah
would it be something that would be uh
the proper thing to do for the vice
president
who i haven't heard a thing from by the
way well he went on vacation this
week pence went on vacation to florida
this week no i mean
you bring up a good question so there's
two questions would it be appropriate to
remove trump via the 25th amendment of
course it would and it would have been
appropriate years ago
is it going to happen in the last nine
weeks or however many weeks
he has of his presidency it's not
because it depends on his cabinet and
the vice president and they're they're
not going to do it so
yes it would be appropriate no it's not
going to happen
it just seems like i'm afraid that he's
going to intentionally
do something that harms this country
that will be very difficult to recover
from
that's completely wrong already yeah
that's completely plausible but um you
know in being hyper realist
trump's cabinet's not removing him you
know laura that's the reality and we
have to deal with uh the cards were
dealt as they say
yeah they paid for their positions in a
sense they did and they are not going to
remove this guy but
listen it's it's down to weeks you know
i guess that's what we have try to
limit damage during the next few weeks
well we've held on this long i think we
can hold on a little bit longer
let's hope so that's my hope that's
exactly my hope but thank you so much
for taking my call
my pleasure laura from richmond great to
hear from you